now for a pride ad some dudes are
modeling women's bathing suits for
Adidas you get the picture I don't need
we don't need to see anymore I've seen
enough
I'm not even totally opposed in theory
to men wearing bathing suits that look
somewhat like this because that's what
men did in the 1920s and like really
old-timey Beach bathing suits but they
shouldn't be wearing these kind of thong
like it should be like full body bathing
suits like the burkini almost but for
men I I could understand that that's not
what's going on here the the suits are
stylized to be as as womanly as possible
and then the dudes who are being picked
to model them are fairly masculine these
are intentionally masculine looking
dudes and it's just to shove it in your
face it's just to beat you down into
submission the purpose of these
commercials is not as the
transgenderists would pretend to
convince you that these dudes are
actually chicks the purpose of these
commercials is to shove right in your
face that these are dudes